well there's still a lot of people um
coming out of urban urpin is the town
nearest to the capital it's the west of
the capital it's basically the gateway
to the capital they're still streaming
out they've only just started doing this
in the last hour or so since curfew uh
lifted we know that there are several
hundred maybe thousand people who are
trapped not just in urban but also
butcher and hostimel which are the all
three towns grouped closest to the
capital
this is what the russian troops will
face this is one of the entrances and
you can see they're they're trying to
fortify
um this we're quite we're about half an
hour's drive out of the capital right
now um and uh
that there are a lot more of these
checkpoints and trenches
built as you go into the capital but
they're basically trying to fortify the
capital because we're told that the
russian troops are within
500 meters of uh
coming out of of urban and have taken up
positions so
if they do make it this far and they're
expecting um the inevitable
i think
fairly soon they they're the roads have
all been littered with these spikes to
try and stop the advance the people are
all
who are streaming out now and taking um
there's no official uh humanitarian
corridor in this area but they are
taking advantage of any lull in fighting
um to try and reach safety which is in
the capital right now and then try and
get if they can out of the capital
they've set up
little first aid stations here and you
can see
some of them are obviously um told us
that they've been trapped there for
many many days in european where they've
been under siege
uh they've they're they feel that
they've been troops have been entering
they talk about seeing tanks there's no
uh food there's no electricity there's
no light there's no water so many of
them felt that that they didn't have any
choice but to try and pull out those are
the ones that we've spoken to if they
are
if they are injured they're taken to
this first aid tent or if they need
some
sustenance many of them are dehydrated
they haven't had access to food or
anything for many days and then they try
and get buses to go into
the capital many of them heading either
straight to the train station which is
absolutely besieged with people on a
daily basis now just trying to get any
trains that they can any transport that
they can out of the capital
the worry is that the capital itself is
going to be ringed and there's going to
be no escape route from the capital and
a lot of people feeling very worried
about the immediate future